do you ever meet Belushi did you know
him and all well I did meet John Belushi
I'll tell you what happened at one time
and it was right when I started I
remember I had done my first movie and
Tom Cruise was in the movie and Tom and
I were meeting with agents there was a
lot of buzz about all these young guys
in this movie I remember this agent took
us out to dinner so we hadn't have no
late dinner and then seeing her to her
car the values of the ballet and then we
gave the valet our ticket and we're
standing on an almost empty Street dark
late night a car a convertible pulls up
and there's two guys in the car and I'm
thinking the passenger in that car is
friggin father Guido Sarducci and then I
look at the driver and the driver looks
at me and the driver asks me do you know
where the Chateau Marmont is a hotel
over on Sunset which is where John
Belushi ultimately died many years later
and it was not possible the John Belushi
didn't know what the Chateau Marmont was
so I don't know in what way he was
messing with our heads
but they saw these two young guys I
guess assumed they were actors and they
blow our minds and they pulled over
eight feet away from listen and asked
directions to the Chateau Marmont and I
answered I said you know where the
Chateau Marmont is he laughed and pulled
away that's the only time I know that's
great